on va commencer par la voile maintenant
j'en ma mère avec une course
complètement folle
on dit que c'est la course du siècle
c'est à dire le vendée globe challenge
13 navigateurs sont partis cet après
midi pour faire le tour du monde sans
escale sans assistance
moi je résume à ça en un seul mot je
dirais que c'est l'aventuré avec un
grand a
alors ils vont partir pendant quatre
mois vraiment tout seul sans croiser m
qui vive
alors vous me direz c'est l'histoire de
moitessier ces histoires de seloncourt à
la fin du 19e siècle
c'est l'histoire des grands qui nous ont
fait rêver de la mer c'est un peu de la
folie aussi pour certains mais si certes
correspond à la folie de chester par
exemple pour lui la définition de la
folie du marin c'était de dire il part à
condition de ne pas rencontrer les
autres donc c'est un pot ça ils vont
partir vraiment quatre mois tout seul
alors il veut ils vont vraiment faire
rien comme les autres et je vous propose
de les voir ce sont 13 hors du commun
qui ont quitté aux alentours de 15h les
sables d'olonne pour le plus grand
périple le tour de la terre c'est la
main du maître de bon nombre d'entre eux
eric tabarly qui à cet après-midi
libérer les traits aventuriers du globe
challenge 10 français deux américains et
un sud africain
treize marins partis pour des endroits
que la plupart d'entre eux ne
connaissent pas partie se faire mouiller
couché par les vagues peur dans les
coins les plus retirés du monde treize
personnages lancé sur les océans pour le
simple plaisir d'être seul face à la mer
soi même et son bateau si la motivation
et communes les moyens le sont moins
pour jean-luc van den heede la course
est assez frais il part sans sponsor
difficulté aussi pour un autre patrice
carpentier le dernier arrivé il n'a eu
que trois semaines pour vraiment se
préparer
ils nous ont battus aux 15000 francs la
semaine sont intéressés donc de se
dépêcher
mais dans une mer déjà formé comme
aujourd'hui avec un vent de plus de 40
kilomètres heure une seule consigne la
prudence car il faut durer un tour
qu'ils espèrent effectuer pour les
meilleurs en 120 jours par les trois
caps sur les trois océans atlantique
indien et pacifique
sans croiser âme qui vive entre les
sables-d'olonne départ et arrivée une
aventure encore plus folle que celle de
1968 lorsque robin knox johnston est le
seul des quatre engagée à ramener son
ketch de 10 mètres swahili au port de
falmouth après 330 jours de mer une
aventure insensée du moins ceux ci alors
qu'il a course gagnée préfère s'évader
partir pour les îles d'où donald
crowhurst l'anglais ne reviendra jamais
mara mythomane il annonce que des
positions et rooney il se suicide avant
qu'on ne découvre la supercherie le tour
du monde en solitaire c'est un rêve un
mythe une aventure qui fascine quelque
chose de tellement immense que jean-yves
terlain portant un habitué préfère en
rigoler ils vont partir pendant 120
jours dans leur petit intérieur de trois
mètres carrés plus ou moins décoré tout
en trompe l'oeil pour loïck peyron plus
fonctionnel et éclairé pour titouan
lamazou proche de l'an 2000 pour
philippe poupon pour certains on entre
dans le v dans le 21e siècle
mais pour d'autres comme chez jean-luc
van den heede ce serait plutôt le 19e
siècle dépouillement total et simplicité
que dire alors de jean françois coste
abords de cacharel l'ancien pen duick
iii le plus petit et le plus vieux
bateau de la course quatre mois à vivre
au sol pour la cuisine le ménage la mise
au point le bricolage ou dans n'importe
quelles conditions est parti
bien mais tout est prévu ou presque pour
éviter toute agression d'humidité tous
les vêtements toutes les pièces
électroniques toutes les piles tout tout
tout tout tout va sous vide même les
petites barres de chocolat et de
noisettes
ces ressources est déjà emballée plus
encore sous vide il vaut mieux car les
conditions seront souvent extrêmes seul
face aux éléments
ils pourront toujours faire la fête au
passage de l'équateur le jour de noël le
1er janvier ou encore au passage du horn
mais tout cela sans jamais s'arrêter et
une lancia manche la guadeloupe plus
jamais s'arrêter de de s'isoler
complètement et de vraiment de vouloir
vivre cette histoire un homme un bateau
de l'océan
c'est de la surenchère pour l' aventure
mais surtout pour cette espèce de
communion avec ce bateau aujourd'hui
c'est la dernière fois qu'ils se voient
pour quatre mois
il sent depuis 15h15 seuls face à leur
destin